now, let me return to the
notebook. I think it's done.
And if we look at our model.
After 10 epochs, it's accuracy has
gone from 36% or almost 37%
to 75% accuracy.
It's loss.
It's loss is well, not very good. It's
not even zero.
But we could have in order to improve the loss function we could increase the
number of epochs but even then.
Our data is a problematic because it's
very small and our neural network
is quite simple. Anyway, the accuracy is not
that so 75% of the time.
we should
Not 75% about 75% accuracy. We should get the
picture that the model is looking. Yeah. So, let's
see how this happens then I'll return and talk about
sigmoid and cross entropy
Well, we only have 15 minutes left. Okay, let me do this quickly.
I am going to upload a picture.
from the c410 database
Okay.
I will use.
cast to load the image
So I'm going to go.
Keras
I'll leave this. I'll leave this out for now just for the sake
of time, but basically I was only going to plot.
The metrics actually, I think
I have the code. I can just copy paste it. So let me copy paste it.
test
images
test I'll be yes.
and the metrics we want this to be
I was supposed to assign to this a variable.
to this mistake
No problem.
I'll share this notebook with you you can run it but what
we need to what we need this, you know the plot it
but I won't plot this right now. I'm just going to comment it out and I'm just
gonna show you sample. Classification.
so I'm going to
Load the image.
sample image
and I will use the
load image function from
Keras
to take this cat picture
Which is from C4.
This is a PNG.
And I need to specify its Dimensions which of course is
32 by 32.
and then
I need to convert it to an array and then normalize
it.
So I'm going to go to sample image.
image dot img2 array
into a numpy array
test
or sample image
and then
sample image
equals
dot reshape
so we have
one sample
That is 32 by 32 or 3 color channels.
And then we want to normalize. So this is normalize.
So what I mean by normalized so we have three color channels
in each color channel the brightest pixel. So
for example, if it's the red channel the most red pixel
will have value 255.
And least red pixel would be
zero.
We want to normalize it because
the Machinery models don't understand.
What these values are?
And moreover if you remember the slides that
we looked at when we I was talking about the Matrix operation
of neural networks. It will throw off our arithmetic.
So to normalize it well we do is we take this sample image.
And since it's a numpy object.
We can divide by 255.
So for number is 255 if it's like in the red Channel It's
Perfectly red. It will be one.
Otherwise it will be 0 so I will not run this.
and
this is supposed to be talking size.
Okay, so if I show you what the sample
images you will see it's
a multimeter basically
and all about this is what we mean by normalized. So this
is 70 to 77% of the pixel.
brightness
okay, then what I'm gonna do is I'm going to use
the predict method so I'm gonna go.
predicted
class
index
will be equal to model.
dot predict
you see we have a distribution.
Which means?
This is the shape.
That the model has predicted.
So remember we said that a machine learning every thing whether it's a
property or a picture or sound bite.
Will be sorry associated with the shape. This is the shape
of the data.
Now what I need to do?
Is use the right code?
Now to understand what this is we need to talk about.
the
the sigmoid or I keep seeing sigmoid here.
We use a soft Max function.
We talk about softmax.
And then we will talk about the cross entropy.